lassen sie uns bitte noch mal kurz auf
donald trump schauen wir haben gerade ja
über ihn berichtet auch über twitter in
dem er koma wieder mit der grippe
vergleicht sie als experte wenn sie das
lesen was sagen sie da was empfinden sie
da ist das für sie ein vergleich die man
ziehen kann oder ist der für sie als
experte unzulässig der vergleich ist so
nicht stimmig man muss sich vor augen
führen dass wir saisonal immer wieder
mit neuen varianten des influenza virus
zu tun haben
demzufolge eine gewisse grund die
immunität haben
dazu haben wir einen impfstoff verfügbar
und so können wir dieser entsprechenden
saison epidemie immer wieder begegnen
beim neuen corona virus ist der fall
dass dieses virus auf eine bevölkerung
trifft die bisher keine immunität hat
gegenüber diesem virus und wir haben
keine impfstoff zur verfügung wir wissen
auch noch nicht ob diese impfstoffe
wirklich wirksam sein können und das
führungspersonal wiederkehrt oder nicht
und wie lange die immunantwort anhält
insofern sitzen wir doch hier in einer
ganz anderen situation und müssen
wirklich alle kräfte zusammen tun um die
pandemie bekämpfung zu schaffen einmal
mit einer haarige mit public health
matches wieder sagen hat maßnahmen zur
öffentlichen gesundheit und hoffentlich
auch relativ schnell dann mit dem stoff
produkten die unbedenklich und wirksam
sind die aber auch verhindern dass
weitere transmission also eine
weitergabe der infektion von mensch zu
mensch statt mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaue ich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren